Сегодня я хотел бы поговорить с вами о
том, как выжимать максимум из общения с
другими людьми. К сожалению, большинство
людей относятся к общению как-то
безолаберно. Они относятся к общению
так, как будто, ну, это что-то такое
естественное, над которым даже не надо
задумываться. Это как вот дышать
воздухом. Вот мы все дышим воздухом. И,
соответственно, какой смысл задумываться
над этим? Но на самом деле это не всегда
так, потому что а-а, смотрите, все
возможности в этой жизни приходят через
людей. Но для того, чтобы возможности
приходили в вашу жизнь, вам нужно
общаться определённым образом. Таким
образом, вам надо научиться правильно
строить коммуникации. Я сейчас не говорю
про тот случай коммуникации, когда вы
просто, а, общаетесь чисто для того,
чтобы поржать, весело провести время с
друзьями и так далее. Хотя даже в этом
случае у вас должна быть то, э, чёткая
цель этого общения. Потому что цель
общения, когда вы общаетесь с друзьями,
у такого общения тоже есть цель. Поднять
ваше настроение и весело провести время
и отдохнуть э таким образом. Из чего же
строится правильное, эффективное общение
для того, чтобы а у вас появилось больше
возможностей или больше людей хотели бы
с вами общаться, общаться или делать
бизнес и так далее? Так вот, прежде
всего, вам нужно ответить на вопрос:
зачем вам общаться? Зачем вам с кем-то
общаться? Поэтому, прежде чем общаться с
кем-то, если вам назначили встречу или
вы сами хотите назначить встречу или по
хотите пойти на какое-то мероприятие, вы
должны чётко понимать, а с кем вы
собираетесь общаться и самое главное,
зачем. Одно дело, когда вы идёте на
какую-нибудь свадьбу, у вас, может быть,
в голове возникнут ответ на вопрос:
"Зачем я иду просто поддержать своего
друга или родственника там в его там
хорошее, э, там важное событие его
жизни". Но в то же время в зале очень
много людей, с которыми вы так или иначе
будете общаться, поэтому очень важно
всё-таки в голове сформулировать свой
запрос. Особенно это касательно теловых
встреч. Зачем вы идёте общаться? Если,
а, условно вы хотите запустить новый
проект и вы ищете партнёра, то сразу
настраивайтесь и и общайтесь только с
теми людьми, которые потенциально могут
стать вашими партнёрами. Поэтому в любом
общении очень важно сначала ответить
себе на вопрос: "Зачем мне нужно это
общение?" Многие люди могут подумать,
что когда я говорю, что чётко
формулируете цель, зачем общаться,
теперь у них вот это пропадёт
человечность, и они всё время теперь как
роботы будут думать, какова цель моего
общения. На самом деле совсем не так. Я
имею в виду а только деловую среду или
среду общения, когда вы вам что-то
нужно, вы хотите добиться какой-то цели.
Понятно, что когда вы общаетесь с
родственниками, вы общаетесь с друзьями,
когда вы просто отдыхаете, вы можете
общаться как угодно. Вы интуитивно
понимаете, зачем вы общаетесь. Вы
общаетесь, чтобы весело провести время,
отдохнуть, похохохотать и так далее. Я
имею в виду деловое общение, когда вы
едете какую-то конференцию, а, на
какой-то форум, когда вы находитесь, а,
или вас позвали на какую-то встречу или
вы кого-то позвали на встречу, когда
есть вероятность, что вы встретите
потенциального партнёра или клиента. Вот
я имею в виду, надо быть готовым именно
к таким случаям. Наверняка у каждого из
вас в жизни, э, были периоды, когда вы
попадали в неловкую ситуацию, когда вам
нужно было чётко и быстро сформулировать
цель вашего общения, либо когда вас
спрашивали, чем вы занимаетесь, а вы
сумбурно отвечали или сбивчиво отвечали
и так далее, вы не были готовы к
разговору. И наверняка были случаи,
когда вы пожалели о том, что вы не были
подготовлены к такому разговору. Либо
напишите другой случай, когда вы очень
много бесцельно общались с человеком,
хотя с этим человеком можно было бы
сделать какие-то совместные проекты,
какие-то совместные дела. То есть вы по
сути бесцельно сожгли а тот то время
общения, которое можно было бы
использовать с пользой. И третье, что я
хотел бы попросить вас, обязательно
напишите, как вы применяли ролевое
поведение в жизни. Я 100% уверен, вы это
подсознательно применяли. И просто
вспомните такие случаи, когда вы меняли
отношение к человеку, и этот человек
автоматически менялся в ответ. Вот это
меня интересует особенно. Второе, вам
нужно чётко определить, с кем общаться.
После того, как вы ответили, зачем
общаться, вам нужно определить, с кем
общаться. Это тоже очень важно. Если вы
ищете партнёра, то ясно же, что
бесполезно общаться с кем попало, там, с
кем угодно, с таксистами, с официантами
и так далее. С кем общаться - это очень
важный вопрос, в зависимости от вашей
цели. Опять-таки третье, ответьте себе
на вопрос: о чём общаться? То есть
заранее сформулируйте в голове
определённый каркас вашего общения. То
есть вы сначала представляете себя,
потом у вас непринуждённый разговор, а
потом вы начинаете, э, там закидываете
какую-то удочку, то есть, э, чтобы
привлечь внимание собеседника и на
вопрос, э, или на его интерес ответьте
коротенькой презентации того, чем вы
занимаетесь и что вы ищете, например.
Поэтому
обязательно
для себя в голове имейте картинку, о чём
сказать, потому что зачастую очень часто
происходит так, что вот вы идёте на
какое-нибудь мероприятие или в
каком-нибудь бизнес-центре, зашли в лифт
и случайно получилось так, что вы
встретили человека, который точно мог бы
стать вашим партнёром либо
проинвестировать, а у вас нету в голове
схемы разговора, и вы начинаете
суммурно, неструктурированно
говорить, что попало. Соответственно, вы
приезжаете на свой этаж или ваш
собеседник приезжает на свой этаж,
выходит из лифта, и вы не добились своей
цели. Поэтому всегда в голове держи
держите определённую конструкцию вашего
будущего разговора с потенциальным
партнёром, либо клиентом, либо там, э,
другим человеком, ну, из сферы ваших
интересов. Четвёртое очень важный
принцип - это для себя сформулируйте или
ответьте на вопрос, как общаться. Вот
здесь интересный момент. Дело в том, что
как общаться - это не про то, как там
держать осанку,
смотреть в глаза, улыбаться и так далее.
Это естественные составляющие. Когда вы
проявляете интерес к к собеседнику, у
вас это должно происходить естественно.
Но я сейчас хотел бы поговорить о
другом. Я хотел бы с вами поговорить о
таком феномене, как ролевое поведение.
Дело в том, что мы все люди и у всех
людей есть определённая склонность быть
предсказуемыми. Это прямо вшито у нас в
генах быть предсказуемыми. Мы боимся
быть непредсказуемыми. Вообще про
непредсказуемых людей в обществе говорят
он неадекватный. Непредсказуемых людей
люди сторонятся. И вообще
предсказуемость поведения, она формирует
доверие. Вот если вы смотрите на
человека, ожидаете от него одно
поведение, а он вдруг начинает вести
себя по-другому, вы понимаете, что этот
человек немного неадекватен, и вы не
автоматически перестаёте ему доверять.
Так вот, вы можете использовать этот
механизм адекватности или
предсказуемости поведения человека. Так
вот, предсказуем человек в рамках
определённых ролей. Вы должны понимать
чётко, что, а, в единицу времени человек
всегда выполняет какую-то роль,
например, роль хорошего отца, роль
бизнесмена, роль руководителя, роль
друга, роль партнёра и так далее. Вы
даже это можете заметить в общении с
некоторыми людьми, как они тут же меняют
своё поведение. То есть, когда,
например, с вам, с вами он, может быть,
держать какую-то официальную м позицию,
а потом подходит его друг, и они очень
быстро как-то переходят на дружескую
ноту, быстро так общаются, как-то на
коротке с называют себя какими-то
сокращёнными именами и так далее. То
есть он резко, а, перешёл от роли там
строгого партнёра или потенциального
партнёра в роль друга. Так вот, когда вы
общаетесь с каким-либо человеком, очень
важно сразу же на него, как пальто,
одеть ту роль, которая выгодна вам. А
какая роль может быть выгодна вам?
Отнеситесь к этому человеку так, как
будто он ваш старый знакомый, которому
вы сильно доверяете, а отнеститесь к
нему как порядочному человеку, как
честному человеку, как хорошему
человеку, как доброму человеку. И вас
это удивит. Вы удивитесь, как на ваших
глазах этот человек начнёт отыгрывать ту
роль, которую вы на него одели. И здесь
ещё очень важно, когда вы в голове
держите роль этого человека и начинаете
к нему относиться как к порядочному,
хорошему, доброму человеку, это меняет
тон вашего разговора, меняет тембр,
меняет вообще ваш внешний вид к нему,
вашу улыбку. И этот человек считывает,
какую роль вы на него одели, и он на
подсознательном уровне будет отыгрывать
эту роль. Это очень сильный лайфхак,
который, я уверен, поможет вам э в
жизни. Ещё приведу пример. Например,
когда вы встречаетесь с гаишником или
любым представителем власти, он приходит
э в роли официального полицейского. У
него погоны, у него форма, он должен
быть строгим. А если вы откроете окно и
скажете: "Ой, брат" или там: "Ой,
извините, там, а вот так-то так-то
получилось, вы мне могли бы помогать".
То есть начнёт ему относиться как своему
брату или, э, причём как к родному
брату, да, или, а, к отцу, или опекуну,
или вот перестанете видеть его погоны, а
будете видеть в нём хорошего, доброго,
отзывчивого человека, вы сразу же
увидите, как изменится и голос
полицейского, и его отношение к вам, и
сразу же пропадёт вот этот холод в ваших
отношениях. Попробуйте, попробуйте. Я
рекомендовал бы вам провести такое
упражнение, когда вот завтра или когда
вы встретите незнакомого человека,
попробуйте мысленно одеть на него роль и
начина и попробуйте относиться к нему
так, а как требует эта роль. И
посмотрите на его обратную реакцию, как
он будет себя весни вести. Этот лайфхак
действительно творит чудеса. В своём
Telegram-канале я даю много
аудиоподкастов и лайфхаков на тему
общения. Ссылку на Telegram оставлю под
этим видео. Подписывайтесь на мой
YouTube канал и следите за свежими
выпусками. Пока.